soan ou là des entreprises privées de
prendre cette décision mais ça doit être
à la justice de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission des clips d'euros
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 17 mars
confinement strict ou seulement le
week-end réponse demain 18h la parole à
jean castex l'île de france et les eau
de france devraient être concernés à
l'échelle européenne l'agencé européenne
du médicament doit rendre son avis
demain sur astrazeneca et la commission
européenne elle a dévoilé son projet de
passeport sanitaires
le ton monte sérieusement entre joe
biden et velimir poutine le kremlin
rappelle son ambassadeur aux états unis
ce soir pour consultations mais veut
éviter la dégradation irréversible des
relations à réaction de moscou alors que
le président américain qualifie son
homologue russe le site de tueurs et
promet qu il en paiera le prix après des
accusations d'ingérence électorale de la
russie notamment
la russie toujours la menace directe la
plus importante selon la nouvelle
doctrine britannique en matière de
défense et de sécurité nationale une
nouvelle feuille de route au royaume uni
pour les prochaines décennies
une analyse que moscou regrette alors
que les relations entre les deux pays
sont au point mort
[Musique]
la france face à la troisième vague de
coronavirus avec elle et régions plus
touchées que d'autres conseil de défense
et iter ce matin suivi du conseil des
ministres de la désormais classique
prise de parole de gabriella talent pour
plus de précisions retrouve en direct
thomas bonnet en direct de l'elysée
bonsoir thomas après une nouvelle
journée de consultation le gouvernement
va donc annoncer des mesures
demain
oui c'est le journée de mercredi a été
consacrée aux réunions du conseil de
défense sanitaire ainsi que de conseil
des ministres une journée qui a acté le
fait que des mesures supplémentaires
vont être prises ces prochaines heures
et comme le souhaite le gouvernement ces
mesures seront territorialisée avec deux
régions qui sont principalement
concernées il s'agit de l'île de france
et des autres france écoutez gabriel
atta le porte parole du gouvernement
c'était donc tout à l'heure à la mi
journée il a été décidé ce matin en
conseil de défense que des mesures
supplémentaires seraient prises dans un
certain nombre de territoires dans les
prochaines heures
des concertations seront amenés par
l'état avec les élus locaux dans les
régions île de france et au de france et
dans les départements qui sont contigus
à ces régions pour partager l'état de la
situation actuelle pour recueillir
l'avis des élus locaux sur les
différentes mesures qui sont envisagées
suite à ces concertations des arbitrages
seront rendus demain avant la
traditionnelle conférence de presse
d'oliver rang qui sera accompagnée cette
fois ci de jean castex une conférence de
presse qui aura donc lieu demain ce
jeudi à 18h et au mague quels sont les
scénarios sur la table
[Musique]
confinement total ou confinement partiel
voici le dilemme est selon plusieurs
médias il semblerait que le scénario
d'un couvre-feu maintenu en semaine
additionné à un confinement le week-end
soit le scénario privilégié aujourd'hui
parlent admise par l'exécutif qui car
c'est dieu qui pourrait donc concerner
les régions de l'île de france et des
oraux de france reste à savoir quelles
seront les modalités d'un tel scénario
ainsi que leur durée
en tout cas si on se dirige
effectivement vers ce confinement le
week-end il s'agirait d'un revirement
dans la stratégie gouvernementale
puisque emmanuel macron avait tout mis
en oeuvre pour éviter un nouveau
confinement de malheureusement les
chiffres ne sont pas bons dans ces deux
régions notamment le taux de saturation
dans les services de réanimation et
thomas demain c'est aussi une journée
décisive pour la campagne de vaccination
oui une campagne qui est quasiment à
l'arrêt puisque la vaccination avec le
astrazeneca a été suspendue hier par les
autorités françaises alors que cette
décision divise y compris au sein des
pays membres de l'union européenne
l' agence européenne du médicament doit
rendre ses conclusions demain le rapport
doit statuer sur la dangerosité du
vaccin et sur les différents cas de
complications qui ont été relevés ces
derniers jours des conclusions qui sont
évidemment très attendu et qui doivent
notamment permettre de s'assurer que les
bénéfices sont toujours plus importants
que les risques en ce qui concerne les
12 d'astrazeneca
merci thomas bonnet en direct de
l'elysée et si le premier ministre
français jean castex vouloir recevoir
une injection du vaccin astrazeneca pour
dissiper les doutes et bien le
régulateur européen rendre à lui on
vient de le dire demain donc un avis sur
les effets secondaires du remède
anglo-suédois l agence européenne des
médicaments qui s'est voulue rassurante
alors que l' oms recommande je cite à
l'heure actuelle de poursuivre la
vaccination avec ce sérum quentin
mauclair makes him abers au coeur des
critiques et de toutes les attentions le
vaccin d'astrazeneca reçoit le soutien
de l' agence européenne des médicaments
ces derniers jours la découverte de
caillots sanguins survenue quelques
jours après l'injection du sérum à
quelques dizaines de patients a provoqué
la suspension de son utilisation dans
une quinzaine de pays dans un communiqué
le régulateur européen a tenu à rassurer
et se dit persuadé des effets bénéfiques
du vaccin britannique au suédois
ainsi pendant que l'enquêté se poursuit
nous sommes actuellement encore
fermement convaincu que les bénéfices du
vaccin d'astrazeneca dans la prévention
de kovy de 19 et de ses risques associés
d'hospitalisations et de décès
l'emportent sur le risque de ces effets
secondaires
l'instance européenne rendra ses
conclusions ce jeudi en réponse aux
déclarations du régulateur européen
bruxelles a rappelé l'importance de ne
prendre aucun risque avec la santé des
populations
comme l'a souligné aujourd'hui l' agence
européenne des médicaments
le nombre total de tels événements parmi
les personnes vaccinées ne semble pas
être plus élevé que dans la population
générale
mais comme toujours nous nous fierons
entièrement à l'examen scientifique et
aux recommandations de la hem que nous
recevrons jeudi pour nous la sécurité
n'est pas négociable
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
réagi ce mercredi l' oms recommande de
poursuivre la vaccination avec
astrazeneca
même si les experts sur la sûreté
vaccinale continuent leur évaluation des
risques pour le moment l'om s estiment
que la balance risque/bénéfice penche en
faveur du vaccin
si astrazeneca retrouve le feu vert des
instances mondiales
quid de la confiance envers le vaccin
selon un sondage et lab pour bfmtv seuls
20% des personnes interrogées font
confiance au sérum britannique au
suédois en comparaison cinquante deux
pour cent des répondants font confiance
au vaccin pfizer biotech
parallèlement le vaccin d'astrazeneca
voit son image écornée par d'importants
retards de livraison le ministre de la
santé olivier véran a annoncé l'arrivée
d'une faible quantité de doses en
conséquence de ces retards ce que nous
savons c'est que ce vaccin est très
efficace pour limiter les risque de
formes graves et donc c'est un outil
précieux dans notre stratégie vaccinale
vous l'avez dit ce que nous déplorons
c'est que le laboratoire à plusieurs
reprises n'a pas respecté les
engagements qu'il avait pris avec les
pays de l'union européenne en matière de
livraisons de doses
et pour ne rien vous cacher les doses
qui doivent arriver dans les trois
prochaines semaines sont infinitésimales
je pèse le mot par rapport à
l'engagement qui avait été pris de son
côté jean castex a appelé l'europe à je
cite montrer les crocs face à ces
retards de livraison jean castex a
annoncé qu'il se ferait vacciner avec le
vaccin astrazeneca dès que possible
objectif remplacer la défiance par la
confiance astrazeneca la question dure
confinement pour l'ile-de-france et les
hôtes france mais aussi le passeport
sanitaire présenté par bruxelles
aujourd'hui que faut-il faire pour
retrouver la vie d'avant un an après le
premier confinement strict c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
avec nous pour en débattre laurent
alexandre essayiste et chirurgiens
bonsoir laurent alexandre merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés fabrice division
avocat spécialiste en droit de la santé
bonsoir à vous aussi fabrice di vizio
merci à tous les deux d'être là un an et
160 milliards d'euros après 1 c'est le
chiffre donné par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui un le coût de la crise
sanitaire on en sort toujours pas un
troisième confinement est donc envisagée
pour deux régions les hôtes france et
l'île de france 18 millions même 23
millions de français concernés
reconfirmer paris c'est une humain vous
dit anne hidalgo d'autant que pour
l'instant pas trop d'effets pour le
couvre-feu con qu'on a eu c'est que ce
serait une bonne solution
la situation sanitaire nous y oblige
fabrice di vizio
moi je suis père jeu peu après minuit je
peux minutes de la santé du mans garde
ce que je sais c'est que je me demande
quand même qui est le fondement de ces
mesures c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné tout ça est devenu on est entré
dans une crise sanitaire on sort avec
une crise politique une crise du
gouvernement
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les mesures
qui sont prises si quelqu'un me donne un
fondement scientifique et bien loué soit
il
parce que tout ça ne rime à rien n'a
aucun sens on fait de la surenchère il
ya quatre semaines fait à deux semaines
on devait tenir quatre semaines
maintenant on confie le week-end mais
attention à partir de lundi les
questions qu'ils reprennent le lift et
en présentiel
on est complètement paumé ça n'a aucun
sens ont fait plaisir aux uns ont fait
plaisir aux autres
la vérité c'est qu'on n'a aucune
stratégie de lutte contre ce virus
depuis maintenant un an
on attend toute la campagne vaccinale il
n'en sortira rien et on est condamné à
vivre avec jusqu'à ce que la situe de
s'ensuivre
l or en laissant dans c'est vrai qu'on
est un petit peu dans la déprime un an
après on en est là se demandait si ça
sera un confinement strict pour les 23
millions de français ou que le week-end
sachant qu'on sait pas trop les effets
du couvre-feu
il n'y a pas eu de vrais chiffres selon
kovy de trek repas
preuve d'efficacité quelle est votre
opinion sur le sujet beaucoup choix
compte tenu du waterloo vaccinale
l'union européenne ayant très mal
négocié les contrats de vaccins elle est
servie en dernier l'union européenne
s'était vanté d'avoir payé les doses
beaucoup moins cher qu israël les états
unis et l'angleterre
le problème c'est qu'elle a payé moins
cher mais elle n'a pas les doses donc
l'union européenne est l'endroit où on
vaccine le moins en angleterre on
vaccine cinq fois plus vite qu'en france
au chili au maroc on vaccine beaucoup
plus vite qu'en france
aux états unis on vaccine également
beaucoup beaucoup plus vite qu'en france
et je ne parle même pas d'israël qui a
déjà vacciner la quasi totalité de la
population à risque et qui est le pays
le plus avancé qui vient de sortir du
confinement et qui a réouvert les
restaurants il ya maintenant quatre
jours donc compte tenu du fait que la
vaccination se fait sur un mode escargot
eh bien il n'y a pas d'immunité
vaccinale significative et donc
effectivement l'augmentation actuelle
des contaminations et la saturation en
cours des réanimations conduit à
utiliser des armes qui sont liberticides
des armes qui sont un peu moyen âgeuse
que sont le couvre-feu et et le
confinement si l'union européenne ne
s'était pas planté dans la négociation
vaccinale on aurait comme les autres
pays développés beaucoup de vaccins et
on pourrait éviter le confinement et les
couvre-feux parce qu'on aurait
maintenant une immunité collective comme
ça s'est passé en israël qui est un très
très beau laboratoire la difficulté très
pratique qu'on a en ce moment c'est que
le variant britannique et 65% plus
dangereux et plus contaminant que les
variants antérieur et donc on se
retrouve avec une augmentation des gens
relativement jeunes en réanimation et la
durée en réanimation est forte chez les
jeunes
parce que on se bat jusqu'au bout pour
sauver les patients job et donc on a une
augmentation du remplissage des
réanimations alors même qu'on n'a pas
une explosion
nombre de morts parce qu'on commence à
avoir une assez bonne protection sur les
très âgés et dans les ehpad où le taux
de vaccination est suffisant aujourd'hui
pour diminuer le nombre de morts dans
les maisons pour personnes âgées
dépendantes mettre des visions on vous
voit lever les yeux au ciel de l'aveu
même des manuels macron il ya deux jours
aux deux jours le virus est finalement
le maître du temps virus est le maître
du tombe à merde alors finir et moi qui
pensais qu'on avait un gouvernement qu
effectivement étaient censés gouverner
je pensais que le maître du temps
c'était le gouvernement qui agissait
alors je ne suis pas d'accord avec
monsieur alexandre mais peut-être sur un
point on peut se rejoindre
c'est à dire que moi je sais pas si un
petit look signal et une bonne ni
mauvaise idée mais quand on fait un
choix il faut l'assumer
à un moment donné si vous voulez je
trouve ça extraordinaire de dire le
virus est le maître du temps alors qu'on
nous a expliqué il ya deux mois et demi
qu'il fallait vacciner
et aujourd'hui on nous explique qu'on
peut plus accéder bon j'ai dit avant
qu'ils voulaient un moment donné
gouverner c'est aussi prévoir ça ses
premiers points
mais le deuxième point il ya quand même
un élément sur lequel tout le monde doit
quand même abandonné se calmer et
réfléchir on est sûrs et d'épidémies
somme toute qui a tué de manière
dramatique
un nombre de personnes importantes mais
dont on voit que même les dernières
études vous disent que peut-être le
nombre de morts attribuées au club il
est à relativiser et à prendre avec
beaucoup de prudence première éléments
deuxième élément j'entends monsieur
alexandre vous dire qu'on aurait des
patients plus jeunes en réanimation
alors je suis très moi je suis je la
prends c'est important que vous me
donniez vos sources monsieur alexandre
parce que moi santé publique france et
parce qu'il dit
la moyenne effectivement d'âge
l'animation n'a pas changé quand ou 80
ans qui bénéficierait de l'effet
vaccinale est donc à ce titre ne serait
plus en réanimation
pardon de vous dire qu'il n'y ont jamais
été en réanimation cette tranche d'âge
il n'y a jamais été en réanimation enfin
le variant britannique qui serait 65%
plus dangereux alors non vous avez tort
que c'est en fait 74 paraît-il dans une
étude sortie aujourd'hui on le voit bien
65 74
sauf que la vérité c'est qu'entre
septembre et décembre
l'angleterre dans les dernières études
una et bien vous montre très clairement
que le nombre de patients en soins
intensifs à lui diminué alors que a
priori ont tous estimé que le variant
britannique il avait déjà
donc moi je veux bien si vous voulez
qu'on dise absolument tout je veux bien
que le but soit à un moment donné de se
dire qu'on va avoir un passeport
vaccinale qu'on va voir ce qu'on veut
mais la vérité c'est qu'on est en train
de tuer les mouches et qu'un canon et
que ce canon qui doit faire des dégâts
collatéraux dont on se mordra les doigts
dans les 15 ans qui viennent à laurent
alexandre la réponse alors
personnellement moi je considère que les
la mort de personnes âgées même malade
et est un drame
et je ne fais pas de différence de
dignité humaine entre les jeunes et les
vieux et donc d'éviter la mort de
personnes âgées pour moi c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'il n'ya
pas de différence dans la dignité
humaine en fonction de notre âge
donc l'argument sur laquelle finalement
on utilise un canon pour traiter quelque
chose de pas très important la mort de
quelques petits vieux c'est un argument
qu en tant que médecin je ne reçois pas
parce que c'est un argument qui va
contre la définition médicale de la
dignité humaine
alors effectivement on ne mettait pas en
réanimation les gens très âgés on le
sait bien aimé ce n'est pas ce que j'ai
dit contrairement à ce qu'a dit m
division c'est bien pour cela qu'on a un
décalage en ce moment entre le nombre de
morts qui n'augmente pas
significativement et l'augmentation
assez forte
déjà en réanimation c'est que on a une
diminution des gens présager qu'ils
meurent sans passer par la réanimation
et inversement
on a une augmentation des cas un peu
plus grave chez les gens jeunes et on a
quand même au moins dans certaines
régions une tendance à la baisse de
l'âge moyen des contaminations et jean
qui est alors et qui va s'accentuer dans
les semaines qui viennent
vous le verrez m divisions concernant le
merapi avec l'augmentation de la
vaccination qui va se faire
progressivement chez les plus de 70 ans
la folie pardonnez moi mais c'est de la
folie vous annoncer des choses à une
heure de grande écoute
est ce que vous pourriez au moins les
sources et santé publique france ou deal
inverse
est ce que vous pourriez au moins donner
des sources monsieur s'il vous plaît
donnez nous des sourds je ne suis pas
d'accord je ne suis pas un problème
j'observe une tendance à la baisse de
l'âge des entrées en réanimation selon
l'observer sur quelques moments vous
raisonnez vous raisonnez en stop moi je
raisonne en flux non raisonnée vous
apporter quelque chose à une route s'il
vous plaît messieurs en province a cassé
attendez attendez attendez excusez moi
mais on vous explique que les patients
sont en réanimation plus jeunes et donc
on est en train d'affoler les
populations le minimum qu'on puisse
faire c'est quand même donner ses
sources
non je suis sage et en cela d'accord
avec abba vous n'êtes pas d'accord si
vous voulez et sophie effectivement
monsieur moi j'ai pris mon opinion
j'exprime l'opinion sûreté publiquement
ses statistiques y compris de l'ap-hp
qui vous montrent que la moyenne d'âge
en réanimation n'a pas bougé je respecte
je reste dans flux sur les nouvelles
entrées en réanimation mais vous avez le
droit c'est vrai que c'est une
information m division qu'on lit ici ou
là et c'est vrai que ce serait bien
qu'on peut être moi même de vous donner
la source c'est vrai convient de ne pas
faire de d'une moyenne d'âge de moins de
3 ans en réanimation mais gâchent mais
je ne vais pas me battre avec vous non
pas avec moi non mais tu prenais un
moment d'oublier non non non non il
s'agit pas de se battre avec vous mettez
l'accent sont quelque chose importante
c'est que celle annoncée une information
qu'on lit un petit peu pas rendues et
qui lit la presse vous effectivement
mais vous avez raison de poser la
question des des sources et de la
rigueur des sources m division on en
vient aux vaccins à présent et les
interrogations autour de l'asra zeneca
suite à l'apparition de plusieurs effets
secondaires vous le savez les cas de
thrombose dans plusieurs pays d'europe
vous le savez un d'ailleurs de nombreux
pays ont mis la pause 1 sur leurs
campagnes de vaccination à l'astra
zeneca je vous propose de regarder la
carte en bleu foncé des pays qui ont
donc suspendu ce vaccin en bleu clair
les pays qui ont suspendu juste 1
l'autriche l'estonie lituanie lettonie
le luxembourg donc une quinzaine de pays
au total mais pas en belgique 1 et
belges ne sont pas inquiet docteur
alexandre où ils ont mieux appréhender
le fameux bénéfice/risque cher aux
médecins non c'est simplement que ans en
belgique on a fait passer les données
scientifiques avant l'hystérie politique
on voit bien qu'il ya eu un effet de
contamination en europe où quelques cas
de thrombose
veineuse ont fait peur en réalité quand
on regarde les gens vaccinés les gens
pas vacciner nous n'avons pas de
différence de taux de thrombose
en france il y à chaque jour avant la
vaccination contre la copie de 19 2 175
nouveaux cas de phlébite afin qu'ils
donnent des maladies graves qui aient
l'embolie pulmonaire
y'en à 275 tous les jours sans
vaccination aujourd'hui on ne voit pas
d'augmentation de ce taux avec la
vaccination et il n'y a pas de
différences de taux de phlébite entre
les gens vaccinés et les gens padacke
signer donc on s'est angoissé pour un
faux sujet l'om est celle agence
européenne du médicament sont
parfaitement rassurante et toutes les
données que j'ai vu jusqu'à présent ne
montre pas d'augmentation du taux de 8
chez les vaccinés
donc on est vraiment face à un cas
d'hystérie collective d'hystérie
politique et c'est dommage parce que on
peut et on peut estimer à peu près à dix
à quinze morts par jour de pause dans la
vaccination parle astrazeneca à ce que
les gens se sentent pas les gens que
l'on ne vaccinent pas y en a un certain
nombre dans les jours qui viennent qui
vont faire des co vide et parmi ceux-là
certains vont mourir donc le principe de
précaution poussé à l'extrême tu il est
totalement déraisonnable d'interrompre
la vaccination parle astrazeneca au vu
des deux des scientifiques dont nous
disposons à l'heure actuelle le
président macron a eu totalement tort
c'est une faute politique
avant de vous faire réagir m division on
va écouter à le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriel attal qui lui avant
la décision donc de l'autorité
européenne du médicament demain a tenté
de rassurer écoutez pas parole du
gouvernement
je veux dire que suspension ne veut pas
dire défiance au contraire la
transparence c'est le ciment de la
confiance alors nous étudions
scrupuleusement les effets secondaires
potentiels qui ont été recensés on a dit
est attendu demain
nous le suivrons et s'il confirme comme
le laisse à penser les premières
indications qui ont été données hier par
le hamas il confirme la sûreté sanitaire
du vaccin
astrazeneca nous pourrons alors
reprendre sans délai la vaccination de
plus belle et avec une sérénité nous
l'espérons renforcer
on le voit arriver gabriela talent en
cas de feu vert demain il espère bien
que les français n'est pas perdu
confiance
entre-temps m division ça va suffire que
jean castex fassent vacciner à l'astra
zeneca que gabriel attal tente de nous
rassurer
la confiance est elle toujours là si
l'attenté qu'elle ait été là un jour je
sais pas mais ce qui me fait sourire
c'est que gabriel apple nous explique
qu'on reprendra sans délai une
vaccination avec des vaccins qu'on a pas
répond c'est pas grave ça montre un peu
le niveau chinois auquel on se situe toi
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné vous
avez quelqu'un qui vient vous expliquer
qu'on va reprendre la vaccination sans
délai alors que trois minutes avant le
ministre vous a expliqué à l'assemblée
qu'on est pas les 12 mais bon
le fait est que si vous voulez sur la
question de la suspension
il ya deux choses hein assure l'ex
andres juste effectivement on est
d'accord est une décision politique
c'est une décision politique mais parce
que on a fait un choix est-il bon et
qu'il mauvais ça c'est un autre débat
mais le principe de précaution on l'a
constitutionnaliser donc à un moment
donné on va essayé de s'appliquer les
règles quand on vote et des règles qu'on
est con un store chinois jamais y
arriver quand même donc ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que si vous voulez je suis sensible à
l'argument selon lequel de nouveaux ont
fait appel au pathos si je n'accepte pas
il y aura dix à quinze morts par jour
qu'il me soit permis de dire quelqu'un a
même eu des morts à cause en tout cas
concomitamment aux vaccins quand même
bon mais c'est pas grave non habana
derniers mois dit pas non monsieur me
dit pas non géant venu de padang
puis on a des exemples tous les jours ne
serait ce qu en ehpad où des gens
regardez en israël vous avez un pic de
mortalité au moment où ils ont commencé
à vaccination en arabie saoudite chane
shun n'ont pas voté se passerait pas on
va reprendre les précieux enfin monsieur
le problème c'est que vous dites qu'il
fait pas grève entre la vaccination et
l'image est presque aussi parce que j'ai
dit ce n'est pas ce qu'une réalité
alors non je ne parle d'abord je parle
de ce que je veux vous aussi vous devez
bien donc ça c'est le premier point il
deuxième fois c'est que en l'occurrence
effectivement vous m'expliquer que à
cause de l'absence de vaccination des
gens seront morts donc c'est vous qui
faites une causalité
je l'a rétablie dans les mêmes
circonstances en vous disant que la
vaccination on observe une concomitance
également de décès
donc si vous voulez faire un calcul
arithmétique retirer cela laurent
alexandre vous qu'ils fussent oui
allez-y pour la réponse non je pense
qu'aujourd'hui notre seule chance de
sortir des mesures liberticides qui
finissent par être insupportable c'est
la stratégie à l'israélienne à l'anglais
joue à l'américaine à la chilienne à la
marocaine de de vacciner très très vite
les règles de l'europe laurent alexandre
pardonnez-moi mais s'affranchir des
règles de l'europe comme l'ont fait
certains pays d'ailleurs européen il
faut il faut il faut vacciner il faut
s'échiner comme l'a fait le premier
ministre israélien à avoir le maximum de
doses vaccinales
il faut et évoqué la possibilité de
vacciner avec le avec le vaccin russe
pour sortir le plus vite possible des
confinement et des couvre feux
c'est pour ça que je trouve que la
position du premier ministre jean castex
de se faire vacciner à l'astra zeneca
est une très très bonne chose et c'est
aussi pour cela que je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure le la décision de macron d'
interrompre la vaccination par là ce
tracé des cas était une faute politique
un bon point pour castex et un mauvais
point pour emmanuel macron qui a eu tort
mettre des vidéos je sens que comme vous
voulez réagir aux propos de laurent
alexandre mais moi je voudrais vous
faire réagir et quelque chose d'autre
s'il vous plaît le passeport vaccinale
parce qu'on arrive à la fin d'un débat
animé on arrive bientôt au bout
le passeport vert qu'a été présentée
aujourd'hui par la commission européenne
a pour sauver la saison estivale alors
en deux mots un le document sera dotée
d'un code qr il attestera que son
titulaire soit s'est fait vacciner
contrôle covit soit à passer un test pcr
négatif ou est immunisé à la suite de
son affection serre est la seule
solution pour retrouver notre liberté
fabrice di vizio
non je suis pas d'accord il faut
également nommé ferait pas assez loin il
vous faut la grippe aussi il vous faut
les angines
il vous faut la tuberculose et puis
pensez au détecteur de métaux et puis
l'obésité et le diabète c'est important
dans les restaurants et puis moi je
propose effectivement tout simplement
d'arriver que son dossier médical
puisqu'on y est ça va plus vite
comme ça au moins on a réglé le problème
si vous voulez plus qu'on en ait dans
les mesures absurdes et stupides
allons jusqu'au bout assumons je veux
dire assumons l'agression du coin
d'icade monsieur alexandre monsieur
laurent alexandre rêve d'une société à
l'israélienne où on vend les données de
santé au laboratoire faisons le on rêve
d'une société israélienne où
effectivement on vaccine à tour de bras
des populations qui ne sont pas à risque
avec une amie avec une année même
conditionnelle faisons le pas de
problème
érigeant une société de la police ou la
police devient la règle et la liberté
l'exception c'est le monde nouveau c'est
la société nouvelle youpi tout le monde
est content on sera tous fliqués et tous
effectivement piché mais c'est le
nouveau monde
c'est là j'ai le sens de l'histoire
alors laurent alexandre ne s'est pas
encore exprimé sur le passeport vert
c'est une bonne solution quand vous
laurent alexandre ce sera le mot de la
fin je pense que ça va être compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre en europe parce que si
l'europe gère aussi bien passeport vers
kehl à gérer l'achat dès l'achat des
vaccins on n'est pas barré si on pouvait
avoir une solution à l'israélienne avec
un pass vert pour les gens qui ont des
anticorps une pcr négatives et les gens
qui ont été vaccinés je pense que ce
serait une bonne chose pour retrouver
une vie normale et les scènes de rues
des villes israéliennes joyeuse avec les
gens qui vont au restaurant je trouve
que c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus drôle
que le confinement du week-end que les
français vont avoir dans les jours qui
viennent
merci laurent laissant de réponse à
demain 18h avec la petite conférence de
presse hebdomadaire de jean castex
effectivement laurent alexandre merci et
fabrice leamy divisio merci à vous aussi
à d'abord accepté ce face à face en
direct sur rt france restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
moscou visé très durement par washington
le président joe biden qui qualifie son
homologue vladimir poutine je cite deux
tueurs dénué dames la russie s'estime
insultée
un rapport des services de renseignement
américains publiés hier accusait
également moscou d' ingérence présumée
dans l'élection présidentielle
américaine de novembre
n'y est resté avec nous sur rtl
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds quo politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille les idées
courageuse des mots qui compte c'est
qu'on soit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême du
cese tous les témoins de notre époque
sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
francs si vous nous rejoignez rien ne va
plus entre joe biden et vladimir poutine
le premier qualifié le deuxième de tueur
sur la chaîne bbc précisant que le
président russe
on paiera le prix une attaque contre la
russie selon moscou une escalade verbale
qui envenime sérieusement la relation
entre les deux pays déjà mises à mal par
l'arrivée de joe biden à la maison
blanche
washington qui accuse également moscou
d'ingérence électorale pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons en direct
tout de suite
antoine claireaux notre correspondant à
moscou un bon soir antoine interrogé
donc par un journaliste le président
américain s'est montré particulièrement
véhément contre eux vladimir poutine
quand nous connaissons de haute tension
entre washington et moscou
et surtout dans le cadre un petit peu
plus spécifique des accusations
d'ingérence russe dans les élections
présidentielles américaines
c'est donc dans ce contexte que joe
biden était invité à s'exprimer sur
vladimir poutine et il ne s'est pas fait
prier je vous laisse écouter vous pensez
que vladimir poutine est un tueur
oui je le pense quel prix doit-il payer
le prix qu'il doit payer
vous le verrez rapidement plusieurs
responsables politiques ont d'ores et
déjà réagi le président de la douma qui
est donc la chambre basse du parlement a
qualifié cette attaque verbale d'
insulte envers tous les russes la porte
parole de la diplomatie russe a fait
savoir que l'ambassadeur de russie à
washington a été rappelé à moscou pour
consultation afin de faire le point sur
les suites à donner à cette affaire
cette déclaration de joe biden risque
donc bien de laisser des traces pour en
revenir à présent à ce rapport du
renseignement américain quelle a été la
réaction initiale des autorités
oui l'administration bagnols l'avait
annoncé et ce dès son entrée en fonction
il n'y aura pas de cadeau pour la russie
ce dernier rapport des services de
renseignement américains qui accusent
encore une fois la russie d'avoir
manipulé les élections présidentielles
américaines va se traduire en sanction
bien réel le porte-parole du kremlin a
regretté l'attitude de washington et a
démenti une fois de plus toute ingérence
écoutez là nous sommes en désaccord avec
les conclusions tirées dans ce rapport à
l'égard de notre pays
la russie n'a pas pratiquer l'ingérence
dans l'élection précédente ni dans
l'élection de 2020 mentionnés dans ce
rapport
la russie n'a rien à voir avec aucune
campagne contre aucun candidat
les autorités américaines l'ont confirmé
dans la journée de nouvelles sanctions
vont être adopté des sanctions dont on
connaîtra le contenu dès demain
reste à voir si l'ampleur de ces
sanctions sera proportionnel aux propos
particulièrement véhément du locataire
de la maison blanche
merci antoine claireaux en direct de
moscou
et pour continuer à parler de ses
relations entre les etats-unis et la
russie nous sommes en direct avec une
photo du borgou président de l'institut
lecanu et en ce temps sénateur rudy
paris bonsoir il faut tout d'abord
remercier d'être avec nous alors un
président qui traite un autre de tueur
c'est assez inédit à ma connaissance
c'est même très audacieux joe biden il
va très fort comment analyser ses propos
je crois d'abord c'est assez grossier ce
langage de mafieux qui est un peu
surprenant pour le président quand même
d'une des uns des plus grands pays du
monde et je crois que là et il me semble
qu'il ya eu un dérapage de du président
biden aux frais de remarques la première
il faut pas oublier que c'est un peu
surprenant que le président biden qui a
été élu quand même à viacom une
hypothèque terrible ce son élection
enfant sait très bien qu'à eu des
fraudes énorme et cie qui se met à
critiquer l'élection soit disant
frauduleuse de 2010 est enfin tout ça
est un peu surréaliste mais je crois que
derrière tout ça et camille l'inquiétude
que les européens doivent avoir c'est
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que depuis
1945 faire depuis pratiquement 75 ans
les etats-unis ont toujours été en
guerre
sauf la période de trump c'est à dire
les quatre ans de trains prenait pas eu
de guerre et là on a l'impression si
vous voulez avec ses déclarations très
agressives du président biden avec aussi
également ce plan de l'otan vous savez
autant 2030 qui veut en serre et les
européens dans une sorte de menace
contre la russie et la chine que vous
avez l'état profond américain qui est en
train de réagir et de déstabiliser
l équilibre du monde moi je suis très
inquiet parce que c'est vrai que nous
avons actuellement une compétition
profonde entre la grande puissance
globale américaine qui a apporté la
guerre et de la paix et puis surtout la
puissance glauque est en train de monter
la puissance globale chinoise et on sent
très bien que derrière tout ça il ya
cette fracture qui est en train de
s'imposer et on voit très bien que les
américains sont furieux alors que c'est
eux qui ont poussé dans les rues la
russie dans la main de la chine sont un
peu furieux de voir que que les accords
russo chinois sont nombreux et je crois
qu'en ce qui concerne les européens nous
avons vraiment à la ceta je pense pas
l'union européenne soit capable de ça
mais je pense qu à des grands pays comme
la france devrait pouvoir réagir devant
cette pression des américains je ne sais
pas ce que pense le président mac cran
mais sérieusement à voir les anglais qui
ont déjà fait leurs plans hier deux pour
intégrer l'otan 2030 à voir les autres
pays de l'union européenne notamment les
allemands qui sont en train dans la
logique de ce qu'on voulait faire assure
du défense européenne un peu d'étouffer
si vous voulez la créativité française
nos entreprises
je suis très inquiet pour l'avenir parce
que j'ai vraiment l'impression que les
américains sont en train d'en serré
l'europe dans un combat futur et c'est
pas ne soyez pas de bonne augure
il faut johnny borgo jean revient quand
même à ces mots durs parce qu'il frappe
effectivement c'est quasiment une
attaque personnelle d'un homme un autre
homme
il se trouve que les deux sont son
président et que c'est a des
répercussions au niveau des relations
diplomatiques néanmoins joe biden
précise qu'il souhaite continuer à
travailler avec moscou sur les dossiers
comme comme le nucléaire mais on a du
mal à imaginer la suite delà de la
relation d'autant que moscou a rappelé
l'ambassadeur ce soir ce qui est plutôt
rare comment peuvent se passer les
choses par la suite lorsque je peux
espérer c'est que ce que je peux espérer
c'est que c'est vrai que la coque
nucléaire est très important entre
l'alma entre l'amérique et et la russie
c'est quelque chose de fondamental alors
je peux espérer que c'est
bon peut dérapages ou un excessive et de
langage du président biden
mais en même temps ils menacent de
sanctions alors déjà des sanctions qui
pèsent sur la russie qui sont des
sanctions un peu stupide enfin qu'ils
n'apporteraient rien soit dans un
contexte de pandémie on a besoin que le
monde s'ouvre et puis vous avez des
européens et les américains qui
continuent à mettre dépend des sanctions
sur la russie tout ça est ridicule
alors qu'on a besoin d'eux lorsque la
pandémie va commencer à s'arrêter à ce
que le monde s'ouvre à ce que les
échanges reprennent en face et pour
l'économie mondiale
et là je suis j'arrive pas bien
comprendre ce que veut faire les les
américains en même temps suivi d'un
autre côté ils peuvent taper pour dire
voilà on peut peut-être mieux négocier
je ne sais pas sérieusement je ne peux
pas vous répondre là dessus à ce saut je
trouve que ces mots là sont des mots
vulgaires et sont des mots qui ne sont
pas dignes d'un président de la
république fin d'un président d'un grand
état comme les les états unis alors nous
pouvons espérer si vous voulez que
damman le bidet ne va pas regretter ces
mots là parce que c'est la logique du
cow boys et cow boy il adore les coups
de feu et même d'écoles tahiti rose
c'est logique des colts mais j'espère
s'ils voulaient que d'ailleurs tous à la
diplomatie américaine un diplôme à cyrus
arriveront à avoir un travail important
de de concertation parce que nous les
européens avons besoin de ça nous sommes
entraînés dans une tension entre la
russie et l'amérique est stupide alors
que le/la la russie est un peu grands
pays européens et nous les européens
nous sommes à cause des américains à
cette tension que mater américain dans
ses relations avec la russie
nous sommes entraînés dans ce combat qui
n'est pas notre combat etc je crois que
ça c'est le le le problème de l'avenir
alors j'espère que les américains
sauront la diplomatie américaine sera
peut-être que plus habiles et mais moins
vulgaire que les mots de biden mais
j'espère beaucoup cela mais vraiment il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya quand même une
mosquée en tout cas réagi avec une forme
quand même de 2,2 de tam si j'ose dire
on parle d' insulte attaques contre la
russie rappelle son ambassadeur on l'a
dit pour des consultations médicales
même vouloir éviter la dégradation
irréversible des relations avec les
états unis
dans ce cas comment ou quelle peut être
la position de la russie qu'elle peut
être l'attitude de la russie face à un
affront même moi j'ai tendance à penser
qu'on l'a vu d'ailleurs ces dernières
années que le président poutine a quand
même une grande capacité d'encaisser les
coups on le voit très bien bon ils
réagissent que tout à fait normal moi je
trouve ça tout à fait normal que la
russie rappelle son ambassadeur pour des
consultations sas et on ne peut pas
enfin le président russe peut pas
laisser dire des choses pareilles sur
lui-même d'ailleurs parce qu'il
représente comme un grand pays
et puis il directement sur son pays moi
je pense que si vous voulez le dans
cette affaire les rageux tendance à
penser que le président poutine comme
les russes vont encaisser à tout en
agissant de façon de façon le lucide et
puis de façon claire en dire écoutez mon
tout ça ça va mais n'allez pas trop loin
et puis j'espère que là la real
politique derrière tout ça prendra le
pas sur des excitations ou sur l'étape
au fonds américain
mais je suis quand même inquiet de voir
cet état profond américain ce grand
complexe militaro-industriel reprendre
la main ça je le sens avec trump si vous
voulez quand vous allez 30 les autres
n'aimait pas trop
alors il y avait une sorte d'union
d'union de l'europe a dit voilà on va
faire des farces open
on doit être indépendant on peut pas
très et puis là depuis qu arrive et me
donne si vous voulez on a l'impression
que la grande volonté europea de faire
une défense européenne
c'est le délire liquéfie et puis on
retombe dans ses vieux travers les
européens qui sont un peu à un peu
dépendants de cette politique américaine
qui est quand même une politique
enfin dans le discours n'est pas une
très belle politique d' équilibre du
monde et notamment du calibre du monde
occidental
justement on s'attendait à un joe biden
assez calme qui jouait un petit peu le
contre emploi face à un treuil parfois
voilà veymont provocateur est ce que ce
n'est pas pire ce qui est en train de
faire joe biden parce que pour le coup
c'est très agressif leur attitude
oui bien sûr le problème c'est que trop
influent était peut-être agressive dans
son comportement il avait le
comportement kéhi énervant qu'il était
tout le monde mais en même temps si vous
voulez être un peu mais qu'est ce qu'il
a fait c'est que pendant quatre ans il
n'y a pas eu de tension il ya plus de
guerre il
elle m'a arrêté tous les conflits
qu'avaient les américains c'est quand
même et sanguinaire est là au contraire
on voit un joe biden mans que l'union
européenne de tout le monde apprécie à
dire voilà la démocratie revient ce qui
vous fait pas pression d'ailleurs ce
soit la démocratie revienne
et puis en fait qu'il se révèle en fait
ce qu'il est le le porte parole d'un
complexe militaro industriel dans
j'espère qu'il arrivera à retenir ou du
moins à ralentir la pression sur la
politique américaine dernière c'est vrai
que c'est le monde à l'envers fais mais
je crois réalise bien se rend compte que
trump avait fait l'union de l'europe et
la bidane est en train de liquéfier là
la petite volonté de l'europe d'être
indépendante
en gros c'est ce qui se passe alors une
dernière petite question sur les
présumées ingérence russe qui reviennent
sur la table elles ont été souvent
évoquée notamment par les démocrates
selon moscou ce rapport avec ces
ingérences que je reviens parce que
c'est un prétexte pour remettre à
l'ordre du jour les questions de
nouvelles sanctions contre la russie
c'est une forme d'explication écouter
entre nous c'est heureusement quand on a
suivi l'élection américaine
présidentielle bon tout le monde allait
oublier ce qui s'est passé mais moi je
connaissais je me suis alors si on avait
fait un rapport il ya 4 5 ans s'est
rendu compte que le système américain
n'est pas un système fiable au niveau
d'élection on s'est rendu compte qu'il
ya eu des fraudes au tout ça est évacué
parce qu'il fallait élire un président
mais attendez ce président qui a quand
même été lu par une des plus grandes
fraudes qu'a connue les états unis elle
avait connu celle d'avec avait fait il
est recalé dit les amériques avait
connue celle qu'avait fait lire aussi
rappelez-vous le fils bush contre la
rapée ou là franchement il ya eu des
excès en fraude qui sont énormes et
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit ce
président kagame telus de façon bon
s'étaient reconnus par cour suprême ça
va mettre fin de façon quand même peu
surprenante et vous avez ce président
qui reprend un vieux débat qui date de
quatre ans alors soit c'est pour faire
oublier qu'il a été lui-même par une
fraude soit c'est peut-être tout chaud
et des raisons si vous voulez pour
relancer l'attention avec la russie
alors y aider comme vous dites peut-être
dans un processus de négociations sur le
nucléaire au trash et pas très bien
parce que c'est vrai que quand vous
commencez à négocier vous avez intérêt à
être dur et puis quand après c'est plus
facile pour obtenir des choses que de ça
mais je ne peux pas je n'ai pas
suffisamment d'éléments pour décrypter
la réalité de ceux de cette offensive
be dead cette offensive un peu vulgaire
peu mafieuses on peut le dire les
cowboys classique avec le colt voilà on
en a tiré son adversaire je tue
l'adversaire c'est c'est pas du monde
actuel ça va pas être devrait pas
exister des mots comme ça entre ddt
président de six grands pays
merci pozzo di borgo d'avoir été avec
nous président de l'institut lecanu et
ancien sénateur udf paris et en russie
dans la capitale moscovite c'est
l'incompréhension également les
habitants ne comprennent pas les propos
de joe biden pour certains c'est même la
colère qui l'emportent
il tente apparemment de provoquer un
scandale il a besoin d'une confrontation
avec la russie ils ont toujours été nos
adversaires ils veulent faire tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour détruire la russie
mais n'y parviendront pas nous avons
dieu de notre côté nous sommes le pays
le plus puissant du monde côté spirituel
poutine incarne la russie il nous
représente en tant que président c'est
la personne qui nous représente tous
ceux ci est en effet une attaque contre
la russie pour une telle déclaration
joe biden devrait être tenue responsable
d'une manière ou d'une autre
vous ne pouvez pas balancer ce genre de
déclarations un tel niveau de pouvoir
cela ne devrait pas être ignorée je ne
prends pas ses paroles au sérieux car ce
sont des propos délirants
c'est un homme âgé il souffre déjà de
sénilité vous ne savez jamais ce que
dira un vieil homme
nous entendrons bientôt des choses
encore plus dérangeantes de la part de
baden j'ai peur qu'il soit démis de ses
fonctions en raison de sa santé
ces remarques sont bien évidemment
inapproprié pour une communication entre
acteurs internationaux
cela ne peut mener à rien de bon si une
puissance nucléaire commence à expliquer
les choses à une autre puissance
nucléaire
même si cette dernière est
économiquement plus faible à quoi ça
sert à mon avis la communication
politique ne devrait pas être ainsi elle
a réussi sur toutes les lèvres des pays
occidentaux manifestement le royaume uni
la place comme une menace prioritaire
dans un rapport publié hier l'ombre fixe
la feuille de route du pays en matière
de relations extérieures pour les
prochaines années
moscou y est particulièrement pointé du
doigt une rhétorique dénoncée par le
kremlin plus de précision avec thé au
combat c'est un rapport qui ne risque
pas d'arranger les relations entre
moscou et londres hier boris johnson a
livré la vision en matière de défense de
sécurité
de politique étrangère du royaume uni
pour les dix prochaines années et site
moscou comme menace directe la plus
importante pour son pays le royaume uni
respecte le peuple la culture et
l'histoire de la russie
mais jusqu'à ce que les relations avec
son gouvernement s'améliore nous nous
défendrons contre l'éventail des menaces
émanant de la russie si d'autres menaces
cités concernent la chine ou encore des
groupes terroristes
c'est bien la russie qui évoque en
priorité le rapport britannique
une rhétorique que ne comprend pas le
kremlin
encore une fois une certaine menace
illusoire provenant de la russie a été
exprimée comme justification mais une
chose est sûre ce n'est pas vrai aucune
menace ne vient de la russie
la russie a été et reste un partisan des
négociations internationales notamment
avec les etats-unis sur la stabilité
stratégique
à cet égard le classement de notre pays
comme une menace est inacceptable pour
nous car ce n'est pas vrai le
royaume-uni aligne donc ses vues sur
celle de washington concernant la russie
boris johnson réaffirmant d'ailleurs que
son pays resterait je cite le plus grand
et unique partenaire des états unis une
annonce qui ne devrait pas aider au
dégel des relations russo britanniques
début mars le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov avait
ainsi affirmé que les relations entre
les deux pays étaient au point mort
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
aplomb blanche maison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanche maison
alors question simple pourquoi la russie
est elle considérée comme la plus grande
menace par boris johnson bon boris
johnson avait devait faire une
présentation de sa future politique
étrangère et il l'a fait hier au
parlement et il n'avait pas beaucoup de
choix puisque finalement après avoir
claqué la porte de l'union européenne
il a comme il l'avait dit présenter se
hisser présenté comme le le meilleur
allié de l'amérique et il s'est présenté
également comme le l'élève modèle de
l'otan et ceux qui n'étaient pas tout à
fait prévu et il a ajouté que le budget
militaire augmentera de 10% par an
pendant plusieurs années et que la
grande bretagne se doterait de nouveaux
sous marins nucléaires actuellement de
vie évidemment surtout de nouvelles
têtes nucléaires actuellement 180 et a
fixé un nouveau plafond qui est à 2 160
têtes nucléaires
ce qui n'est pas considérable puisque ça
correspond à peu près au niveau
dissuasion qu'utilise la france
peut-être une remarque c'est que les
fusées qui porte cette aide du clerc
sont des fusées contrôlé par les
américains des fusées et trident qui
sont contrôlés par les américains est
d'ailleurs les services de renseignement
britanniques sont très liés aux services
américains comme on le sait travailler
en symbiose dans le cadre des 5 eyes
avec également le canada avec
l'australie avec la nouvelle zélande et
c'est vrai que comme il ya beaucoup de
russes au royaume uni est bien assez
souvent le territoire du royaume uni a
été un peu le terrain de jeu d'un
certain nombre de services de
renseignement et on a connu un certain
nombre d'affaires qui sont déroulés sur
le territoire britannique
et puis enfin sur le plan économique
l'origine sonne cherche à conclure des
accords de libre échange avec beaucoup
de pays pour remplacer ceux qui l'aident
qu'il baigne d'anti bénéficier lorsqu'il
était dans l'union européenne mais la
russie n'est pas un sujet et dans ce
cadre là et il cherche plutôt des
accords avec les pays asiatiques
alors prudence maison boris johnson est
il plus indulgent avec la chine
il considère la chine comme un rival
systémique et c'est une un terme que les
états unis avaient également employé
mais contrairement aux états unis il
considère qu'il est essentiel d'avoir
des rapports économiques substantielles
avec la chine
et il compte bien garder les rapports
commerciaux et les rapports
d'investissements croisés il a avec la
chine
par conséquent la chine n'est pas un
ennemi bien sûr il y a les questions de
hong kong
mais après tout on kong a été rétrocédée
à la chine en 97 et depuis cette époque
et bien à hong kong et chinois alors il
y avait bien entendu dans le traité de
rétrocession une indication suivant
laquelle les libertés publiques
resteraient les mêmes pendant cinquante
ans et ça n'est pas exactement ce qui se
passe mais les britanniques se rendent
bien compte qu'il ne peut pas faire
grand chose contre la chine dans tout ce
qu'ils ont pu faire c'est proposer aux
détenteurs de passeports britanniques
d'outre-mer de venir travailler si le
souhaitait en grande bretagne pendant
des périodes de cinq ans est de demander
la nationalité britannique s'ils le
souhaitaient
ceci ne concerne que un petit million de
personnes résidentes à hong kong pour
les autres évidemment ils n'ont pas
cette possibilité alors les britanniques
également son critique sur la le sort
des ouigours dans le dans le soutien
mais grosso modo il ménage la chine pour
des raisons économiques la chine est
loin
c'est un acteur économique très
important et c'est une des deux grandes
différences avec la russie alors cette
nouvelle doctrine britannique
est-elle le signe d'un basculement vers
la région indo pacifique
dans ce document qui fait 120 pages
il y a également la mention de ce
basculement vers l'inde au pacifique et
boris johnson a développé ce thème
hier il a indiqué que lors du prochain
g7 qui se tiendra dans les cornouailles
par conséquent au royaume uni eh bien il
invitera trois pays de cette zone
le premier ministre de l'inde le premier
ministe de la corée du sud est le
premier ni d'australie il rejoint un
petit peu en faisant cela ce qu'a fait
le prénom byden la semaine dernière en
l'ayant une vidéo conférence au sommet
avec le premier ministre indien
le premier ministre australien et le
premier ministre japonais et puis dans
la même dans la même voie boris johnson
a annoncé qu'il ferait en avril un grand
voyage en inde pour sceller la
réconciliation et le développement des
échanges économiques avec l'inde et que
d'ailleurs le port un des porte avions
britanniques seraient dans la zone pour
faire des exercices
naval et bien entendu la grande bretagne
considère que la liberté de navigation
dans les eaux internationales est
quelque chose d'essentiel et le porte
avions en question
il rend naviguer bien sûr en mer de
chine du sud
donc il a claqué la porte de l'union
européenne il en a d'ailleurs pas parlé
l'union européenne dans ce dans ce
document de 120 pages c'est peut-être
une demi-page alors que les relations ne
sont pas très bonnes puisque la
commission européenne à emprunter une
action pour non respect du traité de
break site
en tout cas en ce qui concerne la nex
irlandaise puisque les britanniques
refusent de faire des contrôles
douaniers entre l'ulcère l'irlande du
nord et leur territoire douanier et
cette clause a pour objet d'éviter des
contrôles douaniers entre l'irlande du
nord et la république d'irlande est
essentiel pour la sauvegarde de la paix
merci claude blanchemaison d'avoir été
avec nous et nous avons apporté votre
analyse dont quelques instants rester
avec nous nous reviendrons sur la crise
sanitaire conférence de presse demain à
18 heures de jean castex et olivier
verrons avec des mesures supplémentaires
à attendre dès ce week-end pour les
régions les plus touchées comme
l'ile-de-france face tv
on
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas un à l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et gilet jaune au début ce n'était pas
un mouvement politique le peuple
français était arrivé au bout de ce
qu'il pouvait supporter il ya énormément
de problèmes en france comment se
fait-il qu'on est les impôts les plus
élevés d'europe
comment se fait-il qu'on est les
déficits des plus importants et comment
se fait-il que nous dans les campagnes
on n'est même plus de service public
quand je vois l'état du pays aujourd'hui
honnêtement j'ai mal au coeur c'est
justement tout le sens de la prochaine
élection présidentielle parce que c'est
là qu'il va falloir que les gens
apportent des réponses et moi je crois
que de toute façon on ne peut pas régler
les problèmes avec ceux qui les ont
créés etc c'est impossible
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi la barre est parfaitement
légitime pour qu'on parle de jay liste
on parle de gens qui recrutent des
enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est un guillaume a
qui sont embrigadés ils ont été séduits
ils ont été manipulés et d'autres qui
agissent de manière parfaitement
consciente et lucide je respecterai
toujours l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent
elle conçoit vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
musée de mannheim
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos pieds il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont conquis a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout un questionnement
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre le monde dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
21h merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission toutefois si
les titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
17 mars confinement strict ou seulement
le week-end
réponse demain à 18 heures la parole
sera jean castex l'île de france et les
eau de france devraient être concernés à
l'échelle européenne l'agencé européenne
du médicament doit rendre son avis
demain également sur l'astra zeneca et
la commission européenne a dévoilé
aujourd'hui son projet de passeport
sanitaire jeu bayonne se dit préoccupé
par la violence contre les américains
d'origine asiatique elle doit cesser
martelé un peu plus tôt barack obama
réaction en chaîne après une fusillade
meurtrière à atlanta bilan huit morts et
un suspect de 21 ans arrêté les lieux
visés les salons médecin d'un viatique
dans un contexte de pandémie trop vite
venues de chine
les attentes yaz éthique se multiplient
outre atlantique
au liban le président michel aoun
exhortent le premier ministre saad
hariri a formé je suis rapidement un
gouvernement faute de quoi il devrait
céder la place alors que le pays est en
plein effondrement économique
une demande qui intervient alors que la
population crie son désespoir face à une
situation jugée insoutenable
[Musique]
non
situation épidémique de plus en plus
tendue en france et notamment dans la
région parisienne l'exécutif réuni en
conseil de défense matin ne le cachent
plus de nouvelles mesures renforcées
seront annoncées demain et l'ombre d'un
nouveau confinement plane plus que
jamais sur l'île de france
grégoire douce est comme une épée de
damoclès mise en place dans le
dunkerquois et les alpes-maritimes
depuis plusieurs semaines le spectre
d'un confinement le week-end se
rapprochent inlassablement pour les
franciliens
la mesure qui pourrait aussi s'appliquer
ailleurs dans le pays est bel est bien
envisagée confirme le porte-parole du
gouvernement
gabriella talent il a été décidé ce
matin en conseil de défense que des
mesures supplémentaires seraient prises
dans un certain nombre de territoires et
on peut imaginer que ces mesures peuvent
aller d'un renforcement très fort de
notre politique testée alerté protégé
pour ces départements continuent jusqu'à
des mesures supplémentaires qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à en confinement dans les
territoires où la situation épidémique
est nettement plus préoccupante
le secrétaire d'état qui a détaillé
l'agenda des prochains jours les
annonces officielles sont attendues ce
jeudi en fin de journée le premier
ministre avec le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé annoncera
demain à 18 heures dans une conférence
de presse
les mesures qui seront retenus pour ces
territoires pour une application à
partir de ce week-end en parallèle les
autorités espèrent pouvoir rapidement
levé les récents doute sur le sérum
d'astrazeneca au risque de voir de
nouvelles embûches entraver les
objectifs chiffrés de vaccination dans
les prochaines semaines alors que les
évacuations sanitaires se poursuivent de
plus en plus de familles refuge des
transferts de patients elle plusieurs
trains médicalisé de la région
parisienne en direction de la province
sont reportés ou même annuler un coup
dur en période de tensions hospitalières
les détails en images
oui
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
on pour parler de la situation sanitaire
en france nous sommes avec pierre
jeantet remaniant président de l'union
régionale des professionnels très
personnels de santé pardon des médecins
libéraux d'auvergne et rhône-alpes à
bonsoir berges ont atteint magnan merci
d'être avec nous alors la situation qui
n'est plus tenable pour le système
hospitalier notamment en ile de france
la seule solution le confinement selon
vous confirmant le week-end parce que je
pense que la france est en état de
supporter un confinement va dire on en a
tous marre mais confinement week-end oui
on aurait dû le mettre en place bien
avant
oui mais alors là la question dispose
docteur c'est qu'est ce qu'on est
vraiment sûr que ce confinement le
week-end soit vraiment nécessaire
c'était le cas dans le pas de calais on
ne sait selon qu'ovide tracker il n'y a
pas de preuve de son efficacité
ça va pas encore plus entamé le moral
des français pour une efficacité qui est
douteuse en tout cas on n'en sait rien
alors je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec vous parce que mais regardez les
cif
regardez les xives que l'on a sur le
pas-de-calais sur la région de dunkerque
ça commence à monter ses fruits ils
étaient accrues de mille ans taux
d'incidence ils sont maintenant descendu
à 6 ans c'est pas mal le problème qu'ils
ont si vous voulez c'est que le
territoire de des hauts de france est
tellement imbriqués que c'est pas ça ne
sert à rien on va dire de contingenter
ou de confiner un département il aurait
il fallait qu'on finit beaucoup plus
large tout de suite
l'un vous et efficace alors on a quand
même 106 jours de couvre-feu dans
l'épatant si j'ose dire confinement
partiel donc on n'en parle même plus est
ce que ça a été un petit peu efficace
parce que là c'est un petit peu
déprimant pour les français un an après
le premier confinement strict on est à
la veille d'annoncés en tout cas pour
pour l'île de france ça concerne 23
millions de français
potentiellement re confie nabeul c'est
très dur à accepter ça veut dire que
pour le moment le conventionnement n'a
pas porté ses fruits
qui mais le problème c'est les français
cette année on a quasiment pas eu de
greek peu de gastro entérite
parce que pour durer les gens sont lavés
les mains et ont mis un masque
or qu'est ce qu'on constate sur ses pas
une troisième vague c'est un plateau
depuis la deuxième vague actuellement
qu'on est en train de vivre
qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que au
début de la deuxième vague on avait une
contamination essentiellement par des
clusters dans les milieux étudiants
c'était la rentrée scolaire septembre
octobre
on avait les ehpad parce que là ça
tombait comme à gravelotte et on n'avait
quasiment pas des contaminations
professionnelles
les gens en ont marre et commence à
baisser les bras baisser les bras c'est
à dire que il ya moins de télétravail et
surtout plus de réunions avec des pauses
déjeuner et on a constaté dans ma région
que effectivement on a de plus en plus
de patients jeunes moins de 50 ans est
la cause principale de contamination
c'est la pause déjeuner pourquoi parce
que effectivement vous enlevez le mas
vous mangez vous discuté et un tel
besoin de contact social qu'on baisse la
garde et ça repart il m'a dit il faut
confiné uniquement le week end à juste
titre parce que les français en ont
marre
enfin vous allez les faire travailler on
voyait des enfants à l'école donc ils
vont déjeuner ensemble tout comme les
salariés
et ils n'auront pas droit de sortir le
week end ça ne va rien est-ce que ça va
porter ses fruits vous le dites
vous-même elliott contaminés sont ils
sont quand on déjeune ensemble ce genre
de choses mais parce qu'on ne respecte
pas la distanciation sociale si vous
êtes strict sur la distanciation si vous
êtes à plus de 2 ou 3 mètres
y'a pas de problème le problème c'est
que les gens ne respectent pas moi j'ai
vu sur les berges du rhône si vous
voulez ce week-end il y avait des gens
qui étaient avec des tables et de 10 je
ne comprends pas qu'on ne met pas on va
dire en avant la force publique pour
expliquer à ces gens que là
effectivement il déconne parce qu'ils
font ils font pas ils font courir des
risques et la deuxième chose qu'il faut
comprendre pour les antilles me regarde
c'est qu'on a changé on va dire de type
d'épidémie jusqu'à présent on avait une
certaine visibilité terrible mais on a
mais on va dire des gens qui se
dégradent est passé par la médecine de
ville
ensuite qui a été hospitalisé et au bout
de 56 jours on sait qu'un certain
pourcentage d'entre eux vont partir en
réanimation
on n'est plus du tout dans ce cadre là
maintenant on est si vous voulez dans
des gens qui sont jeunes qui se dégrade
à domicile que le samu récupère et
emmène et constatent à l'arrivée qui ne
peuvent même plus aller en
hospitalisation ils vont directement réa
donc vous n'avez plus ce tampon ce matin
à 10 heures que représente l
hospitalisation ce qui explique la
tension extrême
on va dire dans les services de
réanimation parce que c'est lié au fait
que maintenant on est à plus de 70% de
varier anglais dans certaines zones
alors sachant plus bas les regrets le
moins agressive des trois c'est pas
rassurant ce que momo dit alors parlons
de transferts de patients pratiqué en
ile-de-france en ce moment ça devient
compliqué c'est une situation très
coûteuse
il se trouve en raison d'une information
du jour que finalement beaucoup de
passion refuse tout simplement d'être
transféré
c'est une mauvaise solution mais un
mauvais choix de proposer à non c'est un
très bon soit c'est la seule chose qui
permet si vous voulez de garder à peu
près 10% de disponibilité si vous voulez
sur les lits de réanimation
parce que vous devez jouer entre les
différents services de régulation qu'ils
soient publics ou libéraux de manière à
pouvoir accueillir
maintenant vous n'avez pas de
prévisionnel sur la réanimation jusqu'à
présent que je vous ai dit on savait le
nombre de personnes hospitalisées en
caux vie donc on pouvait en déduire un
pourcentage
maintenant c'est plus tard dernière
question sur l affaire
astrazeneca on attend demain des
nouvelles de l'agencé européenne du
médicament vous souhaitez on imagine
ardemment le retour de ce vaccin pour
autant ça va être compliqué de restaurer
la confiance
ça va être très compliqué de restaurer
la confiance mais c'est toujours une
question de bénéfice risque si vous avez
on va dire quelques cas de corégulation
intravasculaire disséminés pour va dire
quelques personnes en parallèle si vous
ne vacciner pas vous allez perdre entre
280 et 300 dix patients par jour
est ce que l'on doit sauver ces gens là
ça chante maintenant c'est des sujets
plus jeunes
versus une ou deux coagulation donc pour
l'instant sur le territoire français
même si le système de récupération des
données est une vraie passoire
merci la cnam quelque part si vous
voulez on n'a pas de preuve réelle
sérieuse documenté d'un lien étroit
entre la stratégie qu'a et là les
problèmes de coagulation
par contre on sait que tous les jours il
ya 300 français qui meurt donc on va qui
l'on doit avec 6 mai merci beaucoup
pierre-jean intermédiaire d'avoir été
avec ton direct sur ft france
et souvenez vous comment l'oublier
d'ailleurs il ya un an jour pour jour le
17 mars 2020 la france
complètement à l'arrêt sous
un confinement strict pour tenter de
contenir la pandémie due nouveau
coronavirus retour en images sur un
dispositif historique
nous sommes en guerre toute l'action du
gouvernement et du parlement doit être
désormais tournés vers le combat contre
l'épidémie
oui on qui tient en paris oui parce que
[Musique]
quand le moins de risque possible
[Applaudissements]
un malin
[Musique]
c
on a besoin de chacun pour motiver les
infirmiers et les infirmières
les bals à papa des lâches étroits ne
mène pour cela et distillé les hommes de
la spationaute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cour de cassation a rendu son arrêt
aujourd'hui dans la sphère julie une
jeune femme qui demandait que trois
pompiers actuellement poursuivis pour
atteinte sexuelle soit jugé pour viol
elles accusent une vingtaine de pompiers
de l'avoir violé entre 2008 et 2010
lorsqu'elle était collégienne en fait
pour avec à notre reporter katia
technique depuis le palais de justice
pour la cour de cassation julie n'a pas
été victime de viol je rappelle la faire
julie une jeune fille accusée une
vingtaine de pompiers de l'avoir violé
entre ces 13 et 15 ans et cette jeune
fille et sa famille avaient formé un
pourvoi contre l'arrêt de la cour de
versailles daté du 12 septembre 2020 qui
avait requalifié les faits qui me
concerne est d'ailleurs que trois
pompiers en attente sexuelle
toutefois l'arrêt de la cour de
versailles a été partiellement cassé
julie pourra traduire davantage de
pompiers sur la question de la
corruption de mineurs et donner lieu à
de nouvelles investigations alors je
vous donne quelques éléments de contexte
à l'époque julie suivait un lourd
traitement médicamenteux étaient très
fragiles et les actes sexuels avec de
nombreux pompiers avaient lieu par
exemple dans des parkings ou sur des
capots de voiture est souvent en réunion
cet arrêt a de quoi surprendre un moment
où les députés viennent de voter à
l'unanimité un texte de loi qui fixe le
seuil du consentement à 15 ans en
juillet avec entre 13 et 15 ans mais la
loi n'est pas passée et la cour de
cassation a donné raison à la cour de
versailles qui statuez cette dernière en
parlant de julie disposer du
discernement nécessaire pour les actes
dénoncés auquel elle a consenti c'est
marqué dans l'arrêt que je tient entre
les mains il faut savoir d'ores et déjà
que les féministes et des citoyens qui
se sont
depuis de longs mois pour julie comptent
à nouveau manifester en sa faveur et les
avocates de la jeune fille vont réagir
très prochainement à l'arrêt et pour en
parler nos soeurs avec fatima à benomar
militante féministe bonsoir fait la
baignoire merci d'être avec nous il n'y
aura donc pas de procès devant une cour
d'assises au terme de près de dix ans
d'instruction la déception est grande la
compréhension déception et
incompréhension et alors il faut savoir
que ça se passe très souvent comme ça
c'est pour ça qu'ils engrangent ninon de
mobilisation pour avoir un sauvetage à
15 ans c'est parce que très souvent ça
se passe comme ça et d des
qualifications on part du principe que
des gamines de 13 ans 12 ans 11 ans
était consentante donc celle qu'on a
surnommé julie ça a commencé il avait 13
ans on part du principe qu'il était
consentante à des viols en réunion par
plusieurs adultes donc ces pompiers
professionnels étaient tous majeurs elle
avait même pas croire présent d'ailleurs
quand elle a eu le premier malaise à
l'école et qu'elle a fait la
connaissance de l'un d'entre eux et
l'enchaîner des crises de tétanie a eu
plus de 130 interventions entre 2008 et
2010 et l'a fait une tentative des
tentatives de suicide
aujourd'hui les handicapées à plus de 80
% parce qu'elle s'est défénestrée s'est
jetée par la fenêtre et dont cannes
un jour cela ce pompier qui était
intervenu l'emmène chez lui là il ya
deux autres de ses collègues qu'il
rejoigne et c'était le premier viol
collectif tel qu'elle le dit juste quand
on voit la correspondance de ces jeunes
hommes
il l'appelait la coche pour dire
[ __ ] et il faisait tourner son
numéro dans les casernes de la région
parisienne c'est comme ça qu'ils se sont
retrouvés à vingt pompiers qui sont qui
ont été accusés par l donc vingt
pompiers tous majeurs qui savait qu'elle
était mineure et qu'elle suivait un
lourd traitement qui la mettait dans un
état de léthargie entre autres donc là
au début quand ya eu des vins au début
il ya eu un long procès ce pour pouvoir
mettre en examen ces hommes il y en a
que trois qui vont être mis en examen au
début pour viol sur mineure en réunion
ça fait quand même beaucoup de
deux circonstances aggravantes jusqu'à
ce qu'un jour le jour le juge décide de
requalifier en atteinte sexuelle c'est
quoi une atteinte sexuelle
c'est que en gros on part du principe
qu'elle était consentante et en accusant
que trois d'entre eux et les 17 autres
étaient relaxés sous prétexte que selon
eux il connaissait pas son âge alors que
dans les fiches d'intervention des
pompiers qui intervenaient auprès d'elle
l'âge est évidemment stipulé donc là
effectivement il ya un effet
complètement à la chronique l'assemblée
nationale et tous les débats qui a eu
dans la société
je pense qu'il ya un consensus dans la
société pour dire que à 13 ans on peut
pas être consentante à des rapports
sexuels avec des adultes qui plus est
ddd des rapports sexuels à plusieurs
c'est des choses qui contenait
consentant à l'effet que quand on est
nous mêmes adultes et donc bah là le
la famille et les avocats vont saisir la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
j'espère qu'on va on va avoir gain de
cause de cette fois ci fait il m'avait
nos mars et toujours cette voix là cette
idée cette affaire du du consentement
qui revient sur le tapis du discernement
la cour de cassation en quelque sorte a
suivi la loi mais pourquoi la loi
française est elle aussi en retard par
rapport à d'autres pays européens sur ce
point du consentement justement pourquoi
les choses évoluent aussi difficilement
en france on argue que y aurait un
problème de constitution parce qu' il
faudrait toujours dans les tribunaux
conjugent au cas par cas alors que c'est
pas vrai la plupart des pays européens
ont un âge minimal de consentement il
faut savoir qu'en france la des
jurisprudences et l'acte et que que
hockey à moins de 5 ans
on n'allait pas prendre ça mais c'est
ainsi qu'ont éclaté les les scandales de
ces gamines de 11 ans qu'on avait jugé
consentante en 2017 et c'est comme ça
d'ailleurs que les français avaient
découvert cette incongruité dans le
droit français
donc là on nous promet de réprimer
enfin d'avoir un seuil d'âge à 15 ans il
y un rapport sexuel avec un majeur pour
qu'on ne débatte même plus dans les
tribunaux si elle était consentante ou
pas mais très franchement avec ou sans
loi
là on aurait pu quoi caractérisé la
contrainte parce qu'aujourd'hui pour
accuser quelqu'un de violent
il faut faire la preuve enfin il faut
prouver qui a eu la contrainte la meule
viol par violence menace contrainte et
surprise sauf que la contrainte elle est
quand même induite quand il ya des
rapports sexuels qui sont exercées par
des pompiers des adultes c'est à dire
que à double titre il représente une
autorité sur une enfant qui avait à
peine 14 ans en premier au premier viol
en réunion et on lui reproche en fait la
première et auditions on lui reproche de
ne pas s'être suffisamment débattue
enfin imaginez-vous cinq secondes de
votre fille si vous avez une fille de
cet âge là à présent qui a entouré de
plusieurs femmes
et effectivement elle est tétanisée ne
se débat pas ce sont des adultes en face
à elle est donc la première audition on
lui a posé des questions au commissariat
incroyable c'est pourquoi tu n'as pas
j'y ai mis pourquoi tu l'as pas mordu et
pourquoi tu l'as pas pousser et quand
elle raconte bac elle est un peu
tétanisé en lui dit ah ben tu vois c'est
ça la différence entre ça et un vial
enfin moi j'ai été dans des situations
un très intimidante même à plus de 18
ans où j'ai je n'ai pas eu forcément là
ce qu'on peut appeler la réaction la
plus parfaite qu'on attendrait une
victime mais là on parle d'une gamine de
13 ans merci beaucoup
fatima benomar avoir été avec nous pour
commenter donc cette décision
aujourd'hui de la cour de cassation qui
a mené au moins cassé le non lieu dont
ont bénéficié donc plusieurs
pompier merci à vous et dans le reste de
l'actualité pour s'adresser aux jeunes
les politiques investissent les réseaux
sociaux et après youtube et instagram
c'est la plateforme twitch qui a le vent
en poupe
jean luc mélenchon françois hollande
encore jean castex il était invité
peut-être bientôt marine le pen la dgt
razak twitch à la base c'est une
plateforme de streaming gratuite n'est
en 2011 et dont la spécialité de
diffuser en direct des parties de jeux
vidéo commentée en direct par le joueur
aussi appelé streamer twitch ses 15
millions d'utilisateurs chaque jour un
public jeunes de 15 à 35 ans en moyenne
et qui attire vous l'aurez compris de
nombreuses convoitises et c'est donc
naturellement que twitch est devenu en
quelques semaines le nouveau terrain de
jeu des hommes politiques
la dernière en date jean castex le
premier ministre à qui était l'invité du
journaliste samuel etienne et le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'il a eu un
peu de mal à s'acclimater aux codes de
la plateforme et à répondre aux demandes
des internautes sur ce vaccin
astrazeneca qui j'avais le moindre doute
si j'avais le moindre de vous demanderez
la sucent pas seulement absolument parce
que c'est bon de voir c'est ma
responsabilité
bon mais à ceux à ce stade et il faut
avoir confiance dans ce vaccin le
lendemain à peine
emmanuel macron corrige son premier
ministre et annoncent suspendre
l'utilisation du vaccin astrazeneca
mais qu'importe c'est un autre sujet
pour un autre jour quoi qu'il en soit
jean castex avait pour ambition lors de
cette interview je cite ces mots de
parler avec des gens qui n'écoutent pas
forcément les conférences de presse qui
ne lis pas forcément aller leur dire les
choses en toute franchise
un pari raté en croire les internautes
qu'ils accusent plutôt d'avoir opté pour
la langue de bois
malgré sa pertinence mon message a été
ignorée langue de bois
encore et toujours
jean castex il a exactement la même
attitude que s'il était sur le plateau
de tf1
là je suis pas certaine qu'ils aient
saisi le concept de la plate forme après
on se doutait qu'il allait pas parler du
dernier album de booba
mais bon castex pratique tellement l'art
de l'esquivé qu'on se souvient même plus
de la question au final jean castex
n'est pas twitch compatibles ce type n'a
absolument pas l'ouverture d'esprit
nécessaire pour apparaître sur cette
plateforme
quelques jours plus tôt c'est françois
hollande qui se prêtait au jeu de
l'interview sur twitch depuis le
domicile de samuel etienne trois heures
d'échangés un taux beaucoup plus amusé
avec l'ancien président de la république
qui n'a pas manqué de tacler la chanson
gestes barrières de mcfly et carlito
chanson qui a dépassé les 10 millions de
vues et qui permet aux deux youtuber de
tourner une vidéo avec emmanuel macron à
l'elysée je trouve plutôt pas mal de
demandes et les deux créateurs de faire
une chanson est de faire une animation
pour qu'on respecte j'ai écouté la
chanson j'ai pensé quoi qui vaut mieux à
offrir un geste barrière donc y compris
par rapport à la chanson mais pour
s'adresser à la jeunesse encore faut-il
savoir le faire et ce n'est pas qu'une
simple question de format et les
internautes l'ont aussi fait remarquer à
gabriella talent
le porte parole du gouvernement a lui
aussi lancé sa propre émission sur
twitch un plateau qui reproduit trait
pour trait les codes de l'interview
télévisée classique
ici réunis à l'elysée en direct sur
twitter et sur youtube avec des invités
elise fagan malek pourquoi cet
engouement soudain pour la jeunesse d'où
provient cette envie des politiques est
d'élargir leur champ d'intervention
médiatique pour certains analystes
politiques la réponse se trouve dans un
proche avenir
ils sont en campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
ce changement de rythme avec les
influenceurs avec des nouveaux formats
sur twitter ou youtube
sous prétexte de faire passer un message
sanitaire correspond en fait à l'entrée
dans une campagne électorale en période
de campagne les politiques investissent
massivement les réseaux sociaux ils
savent que c'est là que les gens sont
ils sont obligés d'y aller ils
modernisent leurs pratiques il mobilise
des influenceurs dans une démarche qui
comme elle n'est pas préparée et ne
correspond pas aux vrais visages et très
publicitaire de la publicité à petit
prix twitch et les réseaux sociaux en
général c'est aussi et surtout une
absence de contrôle du csa et de
comptage du temps de parole un outil
devenu politique mais qui semble
démocratiquement incorrect reste avec
mon dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de la fusillade meurtrière
atlanta dans des salons de massage bilan
huit morts joe biden se dit préoccupé
par la violence contre les américains
d'origine asiatique et puis direction le
ping du cèdre la livre libanaise a
atteint un nouveau plus bas historique
face au dollar le liban plonge dans le
chaos économique
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement a percuté et on ne peut
pas considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment qu'on repart
à zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité si
le sentiment d'exister d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde est
vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt francs si vous nous rejoignez aux
etats-unis huit morts après une série de
fusillades près d'atlanta les lieux
visés des salons de massage asiatique
des actes anti chinois qui se
multiplient outre atlantique
la police affirme pourtant cet après
midi que ces attaques n'étaient pas
racistes à jordan lui se dit très
préoccupé par cette vague de violence de
détail avec emilie goût gâcher médias et
ce qui fit trois fusillades successives
qui ont visé autant de salons de massage
dans l'état de géorgie parmi les huit
victimes
une majorité de femmes d'origine
asiatique
il y aurait également au moins deux
blessés l'oncle de cette jeune femme a
été touchée alors qu'il entrait dans
l'un de ces salons il a été pris en
charge à l'hôpital et j'ai juste pensé
qu'on ne sait jamais quand on est au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment parce
que c'était si soudan et c'était juste
comme si beaucoup de choses se
bousculaient dans ma tête en garde à vue
depuis mardi soir un suspect âgé de 21
ans serait impliqué dans les trois
attaques selon la police il est
actuellement en détention dans le comté
de crise je crois qu'ils ont lancé des
recherches sur lui et l'ont placé en
détention
le suspect qui selon nous a commis ses
crimes
aujourd'hui dans le comté de cherokee
est donc en détention dans le comté de
crise alors que le tireur aurait affirmé
avoir agi sans mobile raciste le shérif
du comté de chiru qui semble écarter le
caractère xénophobe des meurtres commis
il est encore tôt mais les indicateurs
actuels montrent que ça pourrait ne pas
être le cas il peut s'agir de cibles
d'opportunités encore une fois nous
pensons qu'il a fréquenté ces endroits
dans le passé et qu'il a pu s'emporter
il a insinué qu'il avait des problèmes
d'addiction sexuelle potentiel
et pourrait avoir fréquenté plusieurs de
ces lieux dans le passé mais comme le
chef l'a indiqué il est encore tôt un
drame qui intervient dans un contexte
d'inquiétudes autour de la communauté
asiatique aux etats-unis le président
joe biden se dit très préoccupé par la
violence contre cette partie de la
population américaine
un sentiment partagé par barack obama
alors même que nous luttons contre la
pandémie
nous continuons à négliger l'épidémie
plus durable de la violence armée en
amérique
bien que la motivation du tireur ne soit
pas encore claires l'identité des
victimes mettent en évidence une
augmentation alarmante de la violence
anti asiatique qui doit cesser
d'après un groupe de défense des droits
des personnes asiatiques aux etats-unis
+2 4% de la population de l'état de
géorgie est d'origine asiatique à new
york
la police a décidé de renforcer les
zones fréquentées par les habitants
issus de cette communauté
prêt pour en parler à nos sens en direct
depuis stanford aux états unis avec
allen or avocat c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir à la naure merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on vient de
le voir le mobile raciste de ces
attaques précises n'ont pour le moment
pas été établie formellement mais les
crimes 1 contre les asiatiques ont
triplé en 2020 selon une étude ça semble
incroyable comme information à ce qu'on
a une idée des raisons pourquoi c'est à
cause de l'ancienne administration et du
fait de la tendance à blâmer une culture
pour le virus aux états unis même si
nous disons qu'il n'y a pas de motif
racial
les victimes étaient des femmes âge aux
tic donc pour moi c'est très clair et la
distance entre les trois crime montre
bien qu'il venait une certaine catégorie
de personnes
alors le président joe biden s'est
emparée de la question il a affirmé que
cette violence contre les américains
d'origine asiatique était très
préoccupante
néanmoins il ne fait pas le lien on est
bien d'accord avec son prédécesseur et
ce pointage des doigts quand au chinese
virus il n'est pas très important qu'un
lien soit établi
ce qui est important c'est de savoir la
façon dont la culture fonctionne et il
est très clair qu'il ya une culture anti
ascétique
le président n'a pas besoin d'établir ce
lien nous pouvons établir cette
conclusion nous ma main il y a eu plus
de violence entre toutes les minorités
aux couleurs de lens et l'administration
nous qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
d'établir ce lien
et de nombreuses organisations de
défense en ligne essaye de défendre
justement la population à 6o américaine
est ce la première fois que la
communauté asiatique et prières si
possible ce qu'elle est elle est plutôt
bien de l'intégrer aux etats-unis cette
population l'intégration complète
n'existe pas aux états unis cette
communauté a été pris pour cible à
plusieurs reprises au cours de
l'histoire et toman que beaucoup de
groupes différents par exemple les
japonais qui ont été internés pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale donc ce n'est
pas une nouveauté etc c'est un fait
aujourd'hui d'autres pays essaye de
traiter des sujets qui ont été laissées
en suspens et le président n'ont pas
résolu nos problèmes et ils ont même été
exacerbée par l'administration
précédente elle alors plus que jamais
l'amérique semble fractures et ont
présenté
joba dan comme un président capable
justement d'apaiser un petit peu les
choses est ce que c'est vraiment le cas
whitney houston
il faut que cela signifie certaines
personnes considèrent qu'il faut
accepter de coopérer avec ses
oppresseurs joe biden à un consensus
il faut pouvoir éduquer afin d'améliorer
la situation
la culture le monde du travail
le contexte culturel doit vont
fonctionner de pair et le lac au vide
les problèmes et d'argent on est les
problèmes de chômage attise les tensions
joe biden est arrivé au pouvoir disant
qu'il allait résoudre des problèmes de
droits civiques
mais le président n'ont pas de rivaux
s'tazunis et les états unis qui peuvent
guérir les états unis et teo by donne
travail mais nous avançons et on ne peut
pas il m'a s'imaginer directement dans
une utopie
aujourd'hui avec cette campagne de
vaccination aux états unis on imagine
que vous voyez le bout du tunnel a
contrairement à nous autres européens
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas ce que
les choses s'apaisent
de ce point de vue là aux états unis
je pense que la situation devient plus
facile pour certains ceux qui sont bien
à connecter les personnes qui vivent
dans les régions métropolitaines
elles ont rapidement accès au vaccin moi
même je ne fais pas partie des groupes
prioritaires pour la vaccination
mais dans certaines communautés où ils
n'ont pas par exemple d'accès internet
où ils vivent dans des régions rurales
et ne peuvent pas vraiment se déplacer
il ya plus de difficultés je pense que
les etats unis sont en tête
et une fois que j'ai eus seront résolu
ses problèmes alors dû pourront partager
avec le reste du monde
donc la situation s'améliore mais ça
n'est pas terminée surtout avec
l'apparition de nouveaux variants le
problème sous-jacent continue cependant
problème humanitaire tgh emploi ou de
bien être social
merci à la naure d'avoir été avec nous
pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir les
états unis déborder également par la
hausse du nombre de migrants à la
frontière avec le mexique
l'administration baden a dû faire appel
à l'agencé fédérale de gestion des
secours ce qui souligne l'ampleur de la
crise humanitaire ces arrivées massives
sont liées à l'annulation de mesures
restrictives qui avait été prise par
donald trump
les précisions de clément hospital genou
à terre des dizaines de migrants
d'amérique centrale un plot joe biden de
les laisser entrer aux états unis des
scènes qui se répète jour après jour à
la frontière américaine qui fait face à
un afflux sans précédent
selon le ministre de la sécurité
américaine près de cent mille migrants
en situation irrégulière ont été arrêtés
à la frontière sud des états unis en
février 30 % de plus qu'à la même
période l'an dernier
le pays attend un flux de migrants
historique à sa frontière
j'ai entendu dire l'autre jour qu'il
vienne parce qu'ils savent que je suis
quelqu'un de sympa et que je ne ferais
pas ce que trump a fait je peux le dire
très clairement
ne venez pas pendant cette période de
mise en place ne quittez pas votre ville
ou votre communauté
dès son arrivée à la maison blanche le
président américain signé un moratoire
sur l'expulsion des migrants arrivés
dans le pays avant novembre 2020 mettant
également fin à la politique de
séparation des familles durant sa
campagne
joe biden promettait un nouveau statut
pour la totalité des 11 millions
d'immigrés qui vivent en situation
irrégulière dans le pays pour les
républicains
la situation aux frontières résultera de
l'abandon de la politique migratoire de
donald trump la sécurité de notre nation
et de notre frontière est d'abord et
avant tout la responsabilité d'un autre
président je suis venu ici parce que
j'ai entendu parler de la crise
c'est plus qu'une crise c'est un drame
humain ce qui est triste dans tout ça
c'est que ça aurait pu ne pas arriver
cette crise a été créée par la politique
présidentielle de cette nouvelle
administration
elle ne peut avoir d'autre nom que la
crise bat y donne aux frontières pour
l'heure la majorité des familles sont
renvoyés vers le mexique où leur pays
d'origine en vertu des règles mises en
place pour lutter contre la propagation
du coronavirus mais le pays doit faire
face à une arrivée croissante de
leurs noms d'accompagner qui eux sont
prises en charge par les états unis des
structures d'accueil dédié aux moins de
18 ans depuis bien longtemps saturé
selon la ministre de la santé américaine
en février près de 10% des migrants en
situation irrégulière arrêtés à la
frontière étaient des mineurs isolés et
en bolivie l'opposition est descendue
dans la rue hier contre la détention de
l'ancien président par intérim jeanine
agnès est accusé d'avoir mené un coup
d'état contre evo morales prédécesseur
et dizaines de milliers de manifestants
ont réclamé je cite la libération des
prisonniers politiques les détails dame
à l'assemblée une arrestation qui a mis
le feu aux poudres en bolivie samedi
jeanine agnès a été arrêté pour
terrorisme sédition et conspiration
l'opposante est accusée d'avoir
participé à l'éviction de son
prédécesseur socialiste evo morales des
milliers de manifestants défilent dans
de nombreuses villes du pays pour
soutenir l'ancienne présidente par
intérim à santa cruz
quarante mille personnes ont défilé sur
la place tu cristo redentor
[Musique]
il lieu incontournable des
manifestations de la droite bolivienne à
la passe les manifestants sont allés
jusqu'aux portes du bureau du procureur
général et dénonce un manquement à la
démocratie nous sommes vraiment de
retour pour défendre le peuple d'une
dictature comme autrefois
il y à 54 ans je suis arrivé dans ce
pays pendant la dictature de bancaire et
maintenant je me retrouve en vous disant
que la constitution n'a pas été vraiment
respectée à partir de là on fait des
démocraties avec des arbres un peu
boiteux acceptant tout le temps est venu
de dire assez assez assez
la femme de 53 ans et placé en détention
provisoire pour quatre mois
ainsi que deux de ses anciens ministres
evo morales appelle à des sanctions à la
suite de son arrestation pour la justice
et la vérité pour les 36 morts les plus
de 800 blessés et les 1500 personnes
arrêtées illégalement pendant le coup
d'état que soient soumis à enquête et
sanctionner les auteurs et complices de
la dictature qui a pillé l'économie et
porté atteinte à la vie et la démocratie
en bolivie evo morales a été président
de 2006 à 2010 neuf accusés de fraude
par sa principale opposante lors de son
quatrième mandat
il est contraint de démissionner après
de nombreuses semaines de manifestations
depuis ce jour l'ancien président
dénonce un coup d'état de la part de la
droite conservatrice
jeanine agnès incarcéré dans une prison
pour femmes a dénoncé la décision de la
justice
comme nous l'avons dénoncé le mas décide
et la justice obéit il m'envoie quatre
mois en détention dans l'attenté du
procès pour un coup d'état qui n'a
jamais eu lieu
delage appelle la bolivie avoir foi et
espoir
un jour ensemble nous bâtirons une
meilleure bolivie depuis sa cellule elle
demande également à l'union européenne
et à l'organisation des états américains
d'envoyer des observateurs en bout
vie afin d'évaluer de manière impartiale
sa détention le liban plus que jamais
plongé dans un marasme socio-économique
et une vacance politique sans fin la
population multiplient les
manifestations nouvelles illustrations
aujourd'hui avec une mobilisation à
beyrouth le président a exhorté son
premier ministre à former rapidement un
gouvernement ou céder sa place de son
côté la france appelle à accroître les
pressions sur la classe politique
libanaise pour sortir du chaos remédier
ce qui fit une descente aux enfers voilà
comment les libanais pourrait résumer la
situation économique de leur pays
confronté à une crise sans précédent
depuis 2019
le liban connaît une explosion de la
pauvreté une hausse du chômage une
flambée du prix des carburants une
dégradation des conditions de vie ce qui
a été le point de départ des
manifestations qui ont lieu depuis
plusieurs mois avec notamment des
rassemblements devant le parlement et le
ministère de l'économie
des protestataires qui réclament entre
autres un gouvernement de transition
de leur côté les banques imposent des
restrictions aux épargnants ce qui
complique davantage le quotidien des
particuliers
le dollar est à quinze mille livres
libanaises tout est cher à l'essence est
chère juste manger boire coûte cher tout
le monde a faim les gens n'ont pas assez
à manger les gens sont finis ils vont
mourir ils vont tomber malade
le liban est fini chez le dollar ne va
pas redescendre il va continuer à
augmenter
il va atteindre 25 mille trente mille
livres libanaises
depuis le début de la crise à l'automne
2010 9 la valeur de la livre libanaise a
chuté de 90% par rapport au dollar
les libanais continuent de dénoncer
l'inaction des dirigeants qu'ils
estiment incompétents et corrompus
car au delà de la crise économique se
cache un profond malaise politique qui
dure depuis plus d'un an et demi
cette autorité dirigeante ne partira pas
tant que nous n'aurons pas fait tomber
le parlement et notre révolution
continuera mais s'il ne restait qu'un
seul révolutionnaire
la révolution du 17 octobre ne sera
victorieuse qui avait des élections
anticipées afin qu'on puisse renverser
les personnes la plus corrompue à la
moins corrompue et les envoyer vers un
système judiciaire équitable
d'après l'onu plus de la moitié de la
population vivrait sous le seuil de
pauvreté avec moins de 4 dollars par
jour le prix des produits de première
nécessité aurait quintuplé en un an
selon le programme alimentaire mondial
un bilan qui inquiète et qui pourrait
encore s'aggraver dans les semaines à
venir et pour en parler nous sommes avec
arthur l'an dernier et chef de mission
au liban pour sos chrétiens bonsoir
arthur en dernier merci d'être avec nous
on l'a entendu le liban qui connaît la
plus grande crise économique de son
histoire c'est ainsi qu'on peut
qualifier les choses aujourd'hui
j'ai goûté malheureusement oui
malheureusement oui je vais être très
clair avec vous ce soir je pense que le
liban est en train de traverser la plus
grosse catastrophe de son histoire
vraiment ce que vider les libanais
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment terrible
c'est à dire que ça dépasse même des
communautés nous ne sommes plus sûrs de
chrétiens musulmans c'est vraiment une
catastrophe c'est à dire que cing triple
crise ce qui est en train de subir le
liban on a d'abord une crise économique
on a une crise politique et bien sûr une
crise sanitaire et je pourrais en
rajouter une quatrième avec la fameuse
explosion du port de beyrouth qui a eu
lieu donc le 4 août de l'année dernière
et donc en fait tous ces événements qui
s'accumulent font que le liban est en
train qui simplement de suffoquer et on
ne voit aujourd'hui on le voit de grâce
à vos images que les gens tout
simplement crête je n'en peuvent plus et
justement démontre toute leur colère
aujourd'hui dans la rue alors ce qui
frappe c'est que les pouvoirs publics
semblent absolument impuissant le
président à windsor ministre a changé de
gouvernement ou à s'effacer m'enfin
avant se demande changer le gouvernement
pourquoi non tel but est ce que ce
vraiment cela qui va servir à rétablir
la situation au liban ou dit déjà il
faut vous rendre compte de ce qui s'est
passé il ya peine deux heures c'est à
dire qu'on est le président de la
république libanaise qui appelle le
premier
istres au a abandonné au tout simplement
à former un gouvernement
ça ne s'est pas vu depuis les accords de
taef c'est quand même quelque chose de
très grave d'un point de vue politique
et en effet est ce que le prochain
gouvernement pourra justement trouver
des solutions à la grave crise que
traverse le liban
on n'en sait rien et tout simplement ce
que veulent les libanais c'est un
pouvoir en place qui prend les choses en
main et qui apporte une solution tout
simplement à leurs difficultés
quotidiennes en fait à la crise
économique politique et sanitaire qui a
lieu en ce moment et c'est partout moi
même j'étais sur la route de la baie cas
hier entre justement r'mel et beyrouth
toutes les routes étaient barrées on
sent vraiment profondément la colère des
libanais c'était même une crise qui dure
depuis longtemps et les manifestations
on en parlait déjà en octobre 2019
la fameuse ça ou là comme il l'appelle
la révolution est aujourd'hui et les
choses ne changent pas des choses ne
bougent pas et c'est au détriment
justement surtout de la population
libanaise
comment l'expliquer que les choses ne
bougent pas il ya une vraie cécité de la
part du gouvernement en place et une
mauvaise volonté et la compétence
écoutez le liban malheureusement à
différentes difficultés qui ne date pas
d'hier
le liban se trouve dans une région qui
est malheureusement est très instable
elle a des voisins pas facile ce qui
justement n'aide pas à avoir une
situation économique et politique stable
mais je pense évidemment que le liban
malheureusement subi les politiques de
ces vingt trente dernières années à mon
avis faut pas justement penser que la
crise existe uniquement depuis deux ans
je pense que nous sommes en train
aujourd'hui de payer les conséquences de
mauvais choix politiques et économiques
depuis ces vingt trente dernières années
et on en voit aujourd'hui les graves
conséquences il faut se dire que
aujourd'hui le taux du dollar de la
livre libanaise aujourd'hui seront à
15000 pour un dollar iliad il ya un an
on était encore à 1500 c'est dire qu'on
est passé d'une monnaie de livres
libanaises qui ont marché s'échangeait à
1 dollar et gagne 1500 les produits
balès a aujourd'hui 15 milles c'est à
dire que tous les libanais ont perdu
toute la valeur de leur argent
c'est à dire que tout les épargnes d'une
vie des ehpad une vie de travail à la
banque
les libanais ne peuvent plus y toucher
et également l'argent qu'on gagne au
quotidien leur salaire déjà qu'ils
étaient réduits aujourd'hui ne vaut plus
rien une vraie catastrophe et les gens
commencent
rires de faim vous en parliez juste
avant dans votre petit reportage il faut
se rendre compte qu aujourd'hui 45% de
la population vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté
on parle du liban on parle pas d'un pays
très extrêmement pauvre et cetera ont
peint du pays des cèdres
ce chiffre là est très inquiétant et
j'ai aujourd'hui on le voit d'ailleurs
avec vos images ce qui se passe dans la
rue avec les libanais aujourd'hui
clairement le salut viendra de l'aide
des institutions économiques
internationales
alors oui certes mais il faut se
souvenir ce que disait notre ministre
des affaires étrangères jean yves le
drian qui disait nous voulons vous aider
mais aidez nous à vous aider
c'est à dire que le fmi a été très clair
avec le livre ans dire que vous vous
mettez en place des réformes drastiques
et efficace économiquement ou sinon nous
ne pourrons absolument pas vous apporter
cette aide est malheureusement
l'institution internationale financière
le fmi est toujours en train de négocier
avec les autorités libanaises et on voit
pas le bout du tunnel
donc il faut absolument comprendre
l'urgence qu'il ya aujourd'hui au liban
et donc on compte vraiment sur votre
soutien à ces terres que heureusement
sos chrétiens d'orient essaye justement
de faire le maximum pour les libanais
pour faire en sorte qu'ils puissent
rester et vivre dignement
mais nous avons absolument besoin d'une
présence et une aide internationale pour
le liban si c'est une question d'urgence
l'onu
merci beaucoup arthur l'an dernier
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous exposer
dans cette situation dramatique on peut
le dire je crois au liban aujourd'hui
merci à vous
retour en france diffamation ou non la
cour d'appel se jugent incompétente ne
s'est pas prononcé sur le litige qui
oppose rt français l'ex porte parole du
gouvernement benjamin griveaux ce
dernier qui avait déclaré début 2019
dans mon émission c'est à vous sur
france 5 que la chaîne d'information
était je cite un outil de propagande
un article paru hier dans l'hebdomadaire
l'express juste cette décision comme une
défaite pour rt france et l'avocat de la
chaîne et du site jérémie assous
confirmant que la cour s'est déclarée
incompétente pour juger un ministre dans
le cadre de ses fonctions
les décisions qui sous public va ne
disait absolument pas que rta perdu ils
soutiennent eh ben ce que pouvaient
parfaitement ça qu'on pouvait
parfaitement s'attendre que ils ne sont
pas compétents c'est à dire que ce n'est
pas la bonne juridiction qui est elle ne
peut que c'est une juridiction
c'est-à-dire la cour d'appel judiciaire
le tribunal le judiciaire de paris
également n'est pas compétent pour juger
un ministre pour des actes qu'il a
commis dans le cadre de ses fonctions
on le sait tous puisque c'est encore une
exception française c'est la cour de
justice de la république qui est seule
compétente pour les actes dans le cas de
l'exercice de leurs fonctions mais où
comme chacun sait également alors que
l'ancien président françois hollande
avait dit qu'ils voulaient que cette
juridiction d'exception soient supprimés
ainsi que le président de la république
mâcon une fois élus ils gardent bien de
le supprimer
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
pierre et sa vie verne
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose on
convention